hey everyone out there welcome in to
Market takes it's another exciting
edition of Market today's take of Market
takes today we are looking ahead to the
week There's No Big Data release that
just came out this morning but we're
going to look ahead and talk about all
the things that are going to be coming
up this week to get you ready for what's
coming so you can jump start your week
prepared ready to go hit the ground it
is Monday 10 a.m eastern time here in
New York City uh and I am Dion Robert
Bowen the host of Market takes reporter
at the Wall Street Journal thank you so
much for being with us look here's what
we've got going on right now we've got
this global banking crisis that everyone
is talking about uh globally really as
it's a global banking crisis here in the
US you've got this thing going on with
Silicon Valley Bank big news on that
today we'll get into that in just a sec
also coming up this week we've got fed
chair fed Vice chair for supervision
Michael Barr is testifying before the
U.S Senate and the house we've got ECB
European Central Bank president
Christine Lagarde she's going to be
speaking on Tuesday ahead of some very
important in key Euro Zero Zone
inflation data we've also got an update
on the fed's discount borrowing window
and Global Central Bank holdings that's
going to be big this week also New York
fed President John Williams he is one of
the most influential folks on the
Federal Open markets committee that's
going to be big they are all of course
going to be talking about these banking
issues that have really it started with
Silicon Valley Bank or maybe it started
a little bit earlier with Signature Bank
but this has had Global ripples so
everyone's going to be talking about
that it's on folks mind and we're going
to tell you what to watch out for what
you need to know also the latest data on
recession expectations we also get some
updates on inflation so we're going to
get the conference words consumer
sentiment index on Tuesday or sorry the
conference boards consumer confidence
index on Tuesday and then on Friday we
get the University of Michigan consumer
sentiment index that's coming out we
also are going to get case Shiller home
prices that's for January that comes out
a little bit earlier in the week and the
U.S monthly home price the U.S monthly
housing prices index on Tuesday along
with pending home sales on Wednesday
saying that you're going to definitely
want to watch out for because housing is
a major piece of this inflation picture
and we will talk about the state of
business we're getting Advanced economic
indicators another update on the GDP
report as well as the personal
consumption expenditures report pce the
fed's favorite gauge of inflation that's
coming out this week along with a report
on U.S profits so let's talk really
quickly about the global banking crisis
where we are what's happening with that
the latest news this morning is the FDIC
tweeting uh today we entered into an
agreement with First Citizens Bank and
Trust Company to purchase and assume all
deposits and Loans of Silicon Valley
Bridge bank that's just what happened
when the FDIC took over Silicon Valley
Bank renamed it Silicon Valley Bridge
bank that's what's happening now First
Citizens is a North Carolina based Bank
they're going to take over all 17
branches of Silicon Valley Bank that's
big news First Citizen stock is up 43 at
the open uh this will be the best day
for First Citizens in a very very long
time SDS FDIC estimating the cost of the
failure of Silicon Valley Bank to its
Deposit Insurance Fund will be
approximately 20 billion dollars this
move right now sending markets higher
we're seeing Global stocks up right now
the Dax in Germany feeling some relief
on some of these Deutsche Bank worries
that's up big uh the s p the Dow Nasdaq
all up a little under one percent right
now but moving in a positive direction
remember Credit Suisse was taken over by
UBS and Deutsche Bank shares really
started to Tumble well Germany's
Germany's Dax index which is their
Benchmark stock index equivalent to
basically the s p or the Dow here that's
up big today almost about three percent
earlier today now how did we get here we
put out a report uh last week or a
couple weeks ago it might have been at
this point on how Silicon Valley Banks
collapse is impacting the overall global
banking sector make sure you check that
out we're gonna have that linked so you
can easily find that when you're
watching on on VOD but check that out
basically the big problem was Silicon
Valley Bank made some poor decisions in
not hedging a lot of its bets on
treasuries but the big problem for the
overall banking sector is Silicon Valley
Bank wasn't doing anything different
than what other banks are doing a lot of
the assets basically any asset that you
purchased about a year ago is going to
be worth less than what it was at that
point now so a lot of these Banks when
people are returning and saying Hey I
want my money back I need my deposits
they're saying we don't have it we've
put this in these assets and these
assets are worth less than what we paid
for them now so if we were to sell them
we'd have to sell at a loss and then we
would have less money than what we got
in deposits that's a big problem and if
there were runs on all these Banks the
big five U.S bank Wells Fargo JP Morgan
uh Bank of America those guys generally
would be all right and Citigroup you
throw them in there but for other Banks
there's not a there really isn't a
bright light if if they don't if they
get Bank runs they're not going to be
able to fulfill those because the things
they've invested in whether that's
mortgages whether it's mortgage-backed
Securities U.S treasuries which are very
safe have all lost value over the past
year and treasuries especially the price
of treasuries has sunk significantly so
that gets us to the role of the FED
because the Federal Reserve has really
stepped in here to play a big role
making sure all this happens
um we talk about the FED a lot and the
FED has injected a lot of liquidity into
the system fed Vice chair for
supervision Michael Barr will be
testifying as well as FDIC chair Martin
Greenberg and Treasury under secretary
for domestic Finance Nelly Lang will
testify at a pair of hearings Senate
Banking Committee on Tuesday and the
house Financial Services committee on
Wednesday so those are going to be big
you're also going to watch out for in
terms of the overall picture for central
banks European Central Bank president
Lagarde she's going to speak on Tuesday
and then on Friday you get Eurozone
inflation figures there now that number
was 8.5 percent you saw 8.5 percent year
over year inflation in the Eurozone for
the last month that was back in February
for March if that number is up above 8
that's going to signal that inflation is
not falling remember the ECB raised
rates 50 basis points at their last
meeting that's a very big hike for them
remember rates were negative just about
a year ago and this increase now is
they're moving at a very fast pace and
saying we're not worried about this
banking sector thing we're going to keep
raising rates because we have to fight
inflation if inflation comes in hot this
week on that number for euros of
inflation you could see more worries
about the overall banking system the
health of the economy all that good
stuff on the other side of the coin here
in the US the Federal Reserve has taken
some pretty significant steps to try to
shore up the banking sector I want to
throw something up here on your screen
to just kind of illustrate what we have
seen from the Federal Reserve and and
the overall state of things now the FED
has operated now you're seeing that what
you see is starting at 2020 the fedges
buying up everything what we called QE
infinity and that number kind of goes up
and up and then it starts to come down
as the FED starts raising rates
implementing quantitative tightening or
QT basically not buying any more bonds
and actually letting the ones that they
own mature and not buying them back but
then at the edge of the right side of
your screen you see that line that goes
basically straight up that's what's
happened over the last couple weeks
because the FED has had to try and pour
some water on this financial crisis or
this banking crisis and that's add them
at a lot more to their balance sheets
and we're seeing that number pick up
back towards the nine trillion dollar
figure which is where the FED had
purchased bonds not even uh let's say
five six months ago before they started
quantitative tightening so I wanted to
put that up there just to illustrate the
overall rate of things and and how this
banking crisis has adapted we'll hear
from fed Vice chair or fed excuse me New
York fed President John Williams on
Friday uh and he's going to be kind of
the most influential speaker that we'll
hear from after the feds meeting last
week listen let's talk inflation and
recession worries because those are
obviously on people's minds we get the
conference board and the University of
Michigan's consumer confidence index and
the consumer sentiment index those are
both coming out this week a little bit
about the difference between the two the
conference board is more about how
people feel about business it's more
about how folks are thinking about the
state of business how easy it is to do
business how difficult what they think
how they think businesses are doing
whereas the University of Michigan
survey basically asks hey how are you
feeling how's your financial house how
is everything going for you and when we
look at those really the most important
one I think for consumers and for what
folks are going to be doing where
they're going to continue to spend money
whether they're going to keep buying
things is the University of Michigan
that has been trending up this year but
we've seen some worrisome index
indicators and also how much has this
banking crisis weighs done in consumers
so want to put a chart up here on your
screen really quickly it's the
University of Michigan's consumer
sentiment index you see it kind of went
down going into 2023 but over the last
couple months we've seen that pick up
and will we see that continue that's the
big question
um we are seeing a big decrease from uh
the conference board saying the second
consecutive month uh their index
decreased um this is different from the
University of Michigan index which is up
on your screen wanna take that down
because I think we've Illustrated our
point there with the University of
Michigan but the conference board saying
the decrease reflected large drops in
confidence for households age 35 to 54.
those are the most important household
those are prime earners AKA Prime
workers and for households um 35 and
households earning thirty five thousand
dollars a year or more a lot of
confidence being lost there
um that's that's big and that's going to
make a difference also housing housing
has played a big role in the overall
inflation story because the FED can have
a direct impact on housing by raising
rates they make it more expensive to get
a mortgage make it more expensive for
companies to borrow to maybe get some of
that commercial real estate well want to
throw another chart up here on your
screen and that is existing home sales
now you're seeing the number of existing
homes purchased each month decline
decline decline decline until up last
month you see that number Rising higher
that's a 14.5 percent increase year over
year from the previous year now what
does that mean it means folks are still
going out buying homes taking on
mortgage doing exactly the opposite of
what the FED wants when it freezing
rates to try and get the economy and
trying to get inflation under control
well that's not a great sign for the
overall economy because it means the FED
may have to do more means what it's
doing isn't working so that chart just
kind of illustrates what we're seeing
from overall housing purchases you saw
housing slowing down prices were coming
down prices are starting to pick back up
we will get some more data on from case
Schiller they're going to come with the
January home price index on Tuesday and
the pending home sales index is on
Wednesday that says how many people are
signing contracts before they actually
buy the house but when you when you go
under contract
this report is going to tell us how many
people are getting under contract in the
last month and if that number is picking
up well that shows you overall across
the board housing is picking up people
are spending they're doing the opposite
of what the FED wants may mean the FED
has to be more Vigilant and may have to
raise rates even in the face of this
banking crisis that's what all this
means and then finally we get the pce
report producer or I'm sorry purchasing
expenditures
oh I'm saying the whole word wrong let
me start again the Commerce index the
Commerce department is going to release
the personal consumption expenditures
index that's the price index basically
the fed's favored gauge of inflation it
was at 5.4 percent last month economists
are expecting that to write to fall
below five percent if it doesn't the FED
may have more work on its hands and that
may mean a tougher economy making it
tougher on Banks and we could see more
worries about the banking sector pumping
through Wall Street and start to get
folks worried again we're going to get a
lot of information this week this is a
big week we also get a report on
corporate profits on Thursday last week
we saw durable goods orders fall for the
second month in a row durable goods are
things like cars washers dryers
refrigerators air conditioners stuff
like that we also get the advanced
economic indicators from the Census
Bureau for February that's going to be
your big report watch out for that
listen this is Market takes we are
looking ahead at the week that's what
you got coming up for you this week I
hope I jump started your week really
well and I appreciate y'all tuning in
for more work it takes I hope you will
be back because we will do it again
right here Monday morning on Market
takes I hope to see you there next time